why do you think most people fail in
Hollywood most people fail when they
come to Hollywood yeah well I have to
say obviously there's a delusional
factor where you really think it's not
gonna be as hard as it actually is and I
don't know if it's because humans are
maybe we're inspired by attraction and
like we see what being a celebrity
attracts a very attractive they're
bright and shiny and they play roles
they play instruments you know like I
want to play for a living so they the
people who strive for don't have a real
idea of the hard work and tremendous
luck involved to being one of the few
that actually make it so they're setting
themselves up for failure and that's why
I thought I was always a very practical
person and I thought well if I'm gonna
work regularly and I can't seem to
audition well I better create a
public-access TV show because it was
before the internet and then once the
Internet of my own YouTube tool to use
that was one of my tools another one was
to write a screenplay that I was able to
act in although on Elvis and Nixon the
role that I wrote for myself was given
to another actress who had a big social
media following and knowing that that
stuff happens unfortunately and it's
devastating why do you think some people
are able to pick themselves back up and
continue on some people get mad and say
that I've done if the system's rigged
I'm going I'm driving back I did have
when I was working at the International
House of Pancakes acting like I was okay
with it
I did have a recurring nightmare that I
was being shot every night there was a
regular
customer who'd come in and and I was
wondering to myself why am i showing up
for this yeah and when I woke up I
called my agent and told them to throw
away my pictures and resume I was done I
was done and now at this stage of my
life I can tell you I'm done with being
done I've quit quitting I can't seem to
quit if if there were a way I when
YouTube came along and I started getting
millions of views a month and then
millions of views a week it was like yes
and so I went full on yeah I'm gonna
just do this and of course the views
have dropped down but that was inspiring
- it gave me my own venue but if I were
to do it for the money I could - there's
no money in it although I do get
residual checks but why the government
would take 6 cents out of my 12 I don't
know but I do get residuals as you can
see what's the best year you've had in
Hollywood I thought the best year I
actually did a YouTube video saying 30
year overnight success thinking that
Elvis and Nixon was gonna be the best
year here I written this amazing
screenplay it was nominated and one
words and starving stars know about that
thought that was good and is actually
one of the worst because I didn't
understand although I've made it a joke
in the past how writers can be treated
and it was just not a happy experience
at all however one day I'll be able to
watch the movie and truly enjoy it but
not yet so was that your worst year I
was gonna ask you what was your worst
year you thought it was going to be your
best it that's why I guess it was the
best of years it was the suckiest of
years yeah so both are true and that
seems to be the yin yang the real thing
your
everybody's got something I don't know
anyone who's not dealing with something
and that was my something and I think
that's what you know I tell I would have
told myself in a letter to my young self
it's always gonna be something and don't
take it personally
you're gonna get calls from the big
producers shaming you and telling you
who do you think you are you're gonna
get those phone calls don't get it don't
take it personally it's man doing their
thing to stop you from doing yours it's
always men did you get anyone I've had a
call from a few agents that said okay
occupation oh wow that's general yeah it
would be yes yes and I think that
there's also other things I would tell
her very important see people for who
they really are not who you wish they
were because this is a town of people
who will tell you what they think you
need to hear in order to get what they
need from you so I would tell her to
before Google because this was before
hell it was before laptops I would tell
her you're you're this it's a town full
of people who will misrepresent
themselves and check people out and
don't trust anyone be 80% less Canadian
and 20% more FBI and Canadian is oh wait
you wouldn't hurt me cuz I wouldn't hurt
you eh we're all in this together sure I
hurt you that's like hurting myself well
those little I'm from southern Montreal
south slips and can't believe I forgot
how to do I spent 21 years in in
Montreal and now suddenly I can't do the
accident anymore eight and FBI is guilty
until proven innocent or well in this
town just know that people do take
advantage I was told by my first
photographer let's just call it a
headshot session where he told me after
he took the pictures that all the girls
do this after and I'm like not ain't be
you know all the girls all of them but
at that point you know he had already
given me something and a glass of wine
and I was happy to do it because I was
already freaked out that I wasn't on
that TV show I drove here to be on so
yeah do you think me too
will still exist in this current age now
with this generation going forward
because now we're bombarded with it
every day on Twitter
somebody news being called out male or
female well I know I know someone who
absolutely hates on me too because it
changed but the way they do business and
I'm like okay anytime anything is new if
there's gonna be growing pains and and
right now it's all I getting adjusted as
to what's proper however now that women
and girls and boys are given the words
to use like that is not appropriate put
that back in your pants you know it was
like before we didn't even have this
like oh it must be me was I wearing like
a short skirt and we even though we know
it's not the typical thing is I was
raped
Oh what were you wearing I mean that's
where we're coming from so do I think
it's gonna change overnight no but these
people who are being and and I and as
someone who's been assaulted if you're
being sexually assaulted you're being
assaulted by someone who is able to
objectify you and not think of you as a
purse
and so if you are quiet you are
complicit so not that you brought it on
or not that you let it go on just know
that you have to be a champion you have
to be the hero right then and there and
say if I don't speak up now no one will
and I have a right to no matter if they
bought dinner rape is definitely not
okay not not at all but then there's
this other element which feels like sort
of the elephant in the room in Hollywood
and that is what if there is you do this
for me and I do this for you
well the casting couch has always been
there favors you do favors for people
there has to be that line of not sex it
just can't be you know it's a it's a
hard to change the paradigm what if
somebody thinks they're different I've
got to do this I've got to get this part
but the one thing I see about this town
and having been young growing up not in
in the industry but then coming here at
a very young age with not a lot of
guidances I saw a lot of people like
myself that were very hungry they would
have done anything and I see sometimes
they're still hungry and they're in the
thirties and that's why it's to the
industry they can't it can't be offered
you know it's change dude you know don't
be one of them yeah get your sex
elsewhere get your thrills elsewhere but
I mean for women or men because it's
happening to men as well what would you
tell them that they think that they'll
be offered something if they just do
this and they're willing to live with
that there oh yeah you know if you're
willing to live with that you know if
you're willing to I mean there are
people who have sex for doughnut you
know yeah I would never I never say one
one case fits all however there has to
be now something that we expect and
something that we don't expect and when
the don't expect comes in we're like
I know where to take that I know how to
report sure sure if it's you're waking
up and yeah but otherwise that's worse
like case-by-case right but do you think
we're still in that and that arena now
that there's been so much so many people
have I I would imagine people are more
afraid to whip it out these days
you